- On this episode, we hit the
streets of New York again,
and India gets a fan.
- No (laughs)
(upbeat music)
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is Episode 133
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Just took Misha to her
first baseball game here in
New York City, kind of interrupted
our regularly scheduled vacation.
Obviously cruised into
the city from the Bronx
to take a meeting quickly tonight.
Working tomorrow, doing
another show tomorrow,
so we're squeezing a little
bit of #AskGaryVee in
because all of you were
crying so much, missing...
- [India] The show.
- Thank you India.
You're a little rusty too, DRock.
I was pointing, you didn't even move it.
All right, I guess that's about it.
We're here outside New York City
downtown Broadway and Prince.
Had a good #AskGaryVee
the book call today.
That's getting rolling, that's exciting.
That's about it.
Little bit down on the football season.
I'm a little bit worried about
what I've been seeing so far.
That's my other two cents,
and India, let's get into
- [Both] The show.
- Good job, India.
Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Carlo asks, "What should a
goal be for teachers this year?"
- What should a goal be
for teachers this year?
You know, I'm cynical and tough on
the traditional education
system in the US,
so I would say a goal for a
teacher this year would be
to find one to three
students that are clearly
not predispositioned to be
successful in the machine
that is the education system, you know,
the one that's been built 70, 80 years ago
and is being crammed down
our society's throats
here as the world has
fundamentally shifted, cool.
So teachers, playing within
the rules of the game
that you play, like all of
us, I do it, even though
I'm a wild entrepreneur, we
all do it, we all play in
the confines and the rules
that we set for ourselves.
Try to find one to three
of those kids, and instead
of going through the cliche
things of worrying about
them hitting the marks within the game,
or medication, or all the other
stuff that is being pounded,
maybe take a step back
and open up your eyes.
Especially if you're watching
the show and you're seeing
this advice, we're aligned, all right?
If you're watching more
than two of these episodes,
you've gotten through the stuff
that I'm throwing, and you're catching.
And vice versa, and so we're aligned.
Find the one to three
kids that look like me,
that look like so many of the other people
that couldn't win in those dynamics
but are so, so lucky in so many other ways
to win in the actual
world that we live in,
and try to give them a boost.
Try to be that teacher.
I wish I could sit here
beside Senor Kennedy,
my Spanish teacher in high school.
I wish I could sit here and
rattle off two or three teachers
that saw me for me, and I
could give them daps right now
and say, yeah, you were
right, I was gonna be okay.
Be that teacher for those
one to three students
so that they can, in seven,
12, 15, 22, 39 years from now,
say, Mrs. Boston, she was the
one that knew in fourth grade
that I wasn't made for that,
but that I would be special
at my art or my singing or
my pitching or my selling.
Do that.
- [Voiceover] Joe Asks, do
you think a company staffed
by 50 of your clones would be as, less,
or more successful than VaynerMedia?
- I love this question.
50 of my clones.
Now, there's an asterisk to this answer.
I love being an A, a
number one, and so I don't
like listening to anybody
else, so if you're my clone,
and we can't listen to each other, we may
conflict and may have major problems.
And so the answer is,
if it's a direct clone,
we would crash and burn
and not be anywhere
close to successful as
VaynerMedia because
there'd be 50 people
trying to be number ones.
If I could have one ABCDE,
all the way through Z, twice,
Right, short, because 52
letters, 26 the alphabet,
you know where I'm going.
But if 50 of us could go from 1.1 to 1.50
and go through that ladder,
we would dismantle the earth
and dominate and be the greatest 50 per-
Forget about 300, those warriors that won,
we'd be 50 and we would
dominate the universe.
My intuition is, straight
clones, we'd lose
clones with a tweak,
just an inch of a tweak
that allowed us to have
that 50 person rank
and people listening to each other,
we would dominate earth.
Earth, motherf--ers!
- [India] I know you were
gonna say earth mother-f--ers.
- You did?
Have you gotten that s--?
No way.
- I did.
- We are so
- So in synch.
- [Voiceover] Jimmy asks, "six
years ago you made a video
"called Hey Mr. DJ about curating content.
"Is this still a great opportunity in 2015?"
- Wow, the truth is, I actually, now that
you bring it up, I remember it.
DRock.
Hey Mr. DJ.
Everybody is ready to party.
I agree, and I think that DJ is about
to get the whole internet partying.
I'm just gonna guess, I
have no idea what I looked,
but ahh, much younger, much fatter.
I think that curating
content is an enormously
important skill in a
world of all the content.
She's creating content right now.
I think that in a world of all the
creation of content that's going on,
I think we need curators to help us.
It's why I love Nuzzle so much, right?
Just got in a cab, hit
Nuzzle, 12 headlines
that I want to know about.
Tech Meme, Jason Herscher, by the way,
hope you're feeling better, brother.
His email list, Media Rep.
Yes, curation is massively,
massively important,
and something that I think
that we need in our society.
- [Man on street] Gary!
- Sup, man, how are you?
Sup bro.
Gettin' fans, love it.
- So I was wondering, what do you feel
a high schooler who's really into tech
who knows how to code, has made an app,
should do in order to guarantee success
as a tech entrepreneur after college?
That's my question, thanks.
- There's something about this kid's video
that kind of hit me in the stomach.
What I wanted to say to you is very simply
that, by the way, before I get into it,
it's a good moment to tell everybody
to keep pumping out questions.
I am very much watching
and sending India stuff.
I really want more and more videos,
Instagram or Twitter,
hashtag it, #AskGaryVee.
There's something about this
kid that really stuck with me.
I'm gonna make a weird prediction.
I fundamentally believe
that this kid is gonna be
massively successful and
will email me this video
in 12 years saying hey, cool.
So what I really want to
tell you is to hang around
people that you want to be like.
Is that another person saying hey?
- That was my friend Ty.
- Oh, hey Ty, sup Ty?
India, you can't have more fans than me,
I'll be very pissed.
- He's known me since college.
- All right, whatever Ty.
Hang around as many people
that you want to be like as possible.
I have a funny feeling
you have all the pieces,
now it's about the connections.
Connections are grossly underestimated.
I would intern every summer between now
and whenever your'e ready
to do your own thing
for people that you want to be like,
organizations that you want to be like.
Network.
Networking was clearly the thing that,
I watched the video, and
I was like, network, kid.
Just get out there,
MeetUp.com, meet people,
go on Twitter search,
just say hey to people,
join as many networks,
get yourself out there
into the real world to
give daps, say hi to India
'cause you went to college
with her, that kind of thing.
Just get out there and
say hello to people,
meet as many people, and be
around like-minded people.
Be around like-minded
people, be around winners,
hustlers, ambitious
entrepreneurs, spend summers in
San Francisco, but there's tech scenes
popping up everywhere, but
it's about these five to six
internships that you can
sneak in between now and
the beginning that I think will
have disproportionate value for you.
And don't take an internship
at Facebook or Apple
where you won't ever touch
the genesis, the seed.
Go to smaller places that
are people like you want
to be like so that you can taste it,
so you can be close to it.
- [Voiceover] Corbin asks, "you talk
"a lot about self awareness.
"Do you think this can prevent people
"from pushing past their comfort zone?"
- I'm not sure what Corbin means.
Do I think self awareness-
- Like if you're too
self-aware and you've found
your strenghts, if you're
too self-aware and you know
exactly what you're good
at, will that stop you
from pursuing other things?
- I think this is a very valid
point that a lot of people
in my inner circle of intellectual friends
who are watching what I'm up to and know
that self-awareness is a
theme of mine right now
argue with me that is a
counterpoint to my point,
which I have tremendous respect for,
but absolutely am not
scared of, and disagree,
and honestly believe that that's the norm,
which is why the norm sits
directly in the middle
and doesn't have that upside.
So, yes, do I think if
you're hyper-self-aware
and know that you're
introverted or you just
stay to certain things and you
never explore other things,
can there be some limitations?
I do, but, to the point
of true self-awareness,
if you actually know what
you're best at and what you're
good at, and you spend time there,
you will have the most upside.
So yeah, you could say
that you're not gonna be
as well-rounded as a
person, I would argue that
by far the happiest and by
far the most successful people
are not the most
well-rounded and have gone
extremely deep, not extraordinarily wide.
And that doesn't mean, look,
I think I play all over
the place, but I drill it in
one spot, and so it's about
drilling that one spot, and
so it's a great question.
DRock, keep you busy a little bit
'cause we don't have any shows right now,
throw me up a little bit
of a tremendous alert.
It's a tremendous question.
By the way, DRock, show
this thing, it's really cool.
I just like it, I just think
people should see that cart.
All right, get back here DRock.
It's a tremendous question, one that
a lot of people need to think about,
but my answer is, I
don't want to hedge here.
My answer is, no, I'm not concerned
about that, I'm really not.
As a matter of fact, as I've
gotten older I've become
more educated, more
rounded into more things
because my success has given
me permission to do that,
and I think if you go
deep in the beginning,
that success will come, and
then you can worry about
some of that secondary
things, in my opinion,
which is rounding out pieces.
If you're truly self-aware,
you know what you're good at.
It's not like you missed out on being the
greatest singer of all time,
so that's what I think.
That's the scoop.
Statement of the day.
I remembered, I'm impressed
with myself right there.
I kind of dreamt a couple
times that I said question
of the day, and you guys all yelled at me.
Statement of the day: give me a recap.
I need your two-sentence
recap of the show.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(upbeat music)